[Music]
question. Hey
Good
afternoon. Welcome,
welcome, welcome to the table. My name
is Cat. My pronouns are she and her. We
are so glad that you joined us. Want to
extend a special welcome to anyone who
is new or just here. for the first time
in a long time. We're so glad that
you've chosen to join us
today. For anyone single and seeking a
fun, welcoming, and safe space to
connect, make friends, and enjoy great
company, we have a monthly social
gathering starting in May. It will be
led by Marcy Clark. If you are
interested, please scan the QR code and
navigate it to the table meetup interest
form. Join us one week from today for
our next first Sunday meal on May 4th.
That day, we'll be trying something new
with our worship service by gathering in
the family life center, the the gym area
for the entire time. It will be a great
opportunity for you to connect and
share. Sign up to contri contribute to
the potluck
uh by the QR code and code link tree. We
hope to see you
there. These candles are a sign of the
presence of Christ among us, fully
divine and fully human.
Now we exit the kingdom of
noise, hurry, and
productivity. Now we enter the kingdom
of
silence,
stillness, and
grace. Now we enter sacred space, a
space for
prayer, worship, and
adoration. A space to encounter Christ.
Revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation. Allow the unforced rhythms of
grace to find you, to mend your
heart. May we all come
home. Would you guys go ahead and stand
with us? We're gonna sing um songs. And
before we do, I just wanted to
this part of our worship with um a
passage in Psalm 98. It says, "Shout for
joy to the Lord, all the earth. Burst
into jubilant song with music. Make
music to the Lord with the harp, with
the harp and the sound of singing with
trumpets and the blast of the rams horn.
Shout for joy before the Lord the King.
Let the sea resound and everything in
it, the world and all who live in it.
Let the rivers clap their hands. Let the
mountains sing together for joy. Let
them sing before the Lord, for he comes
to judge the earth, and he will judge it
in righteousness and its people with
equity. And this week, I've just been
thinking about um how easy it can be to
um to feel the heaviness and the weight
of our lives, our busyiness, um some of
the stress of our world. But um I am
trying to hold passages like that where
where we're called to remember joy and
to be marked by joy and to celebrate and
to rejoice. And um I'm trying to hold
that close in my heart and hold it in
tandem because I feel that God makes so
much room for our pain and our stories
and our pasts and also is calling us to
rejoice and to be glad and and to find
the joy of the Lord again. Um so I just
wanted to share that before we start out
tonight. And as we're singing, I am
praying that the spirit of God would
minister to those weary and dry places
in our heart to to help us return to a
childlike joy. Um to remember days where
we've experienced goodness and happiness
and um fun and uh and to be whole people
in that way. So you guys join us in that
and um sing out sing out tonight. We are
small but mighty. So
[Music]
Mercy rising with the rising of the sun.
rushing and filling up my
lungs. Your
faithfulness is here and now. The
evidence is all
around. I bless your name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for
[Music]
singing. Awake my soul. Come on and
praise the
Lord. Today is a day for singing.
Oh my soul.
[Music]
Praise the Lord.
Oh my soul,
today is the day for singing.
A new
song is rising up deep inside of
me. There is new
life. Hallelujah. I have been redeemed.
[Music]
down. I bless your
name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord. Today is a
day. Oh my soul.
Oh my soul.
[Music]
Praise the Lord.
Oh my
soul. Today is a day for singing.
Today, today is a day
for the valley to the mountain, theert
to the fountain.
Oh, I will praise you from the morning
from the morning to the evening. As long
as I am breathing today.
Let's sing that again. From the valley
to the mountain, the desert to the
fountain. Oh, I will praise you
from the morning to the evening. As long
as I can brea in. Today is the day for
singing. Today is the day for singing.
Oh,
today is the day for
singing. I bless your name. I give you
praise. Today is a day for
singing.
Awake my soul. Come on and praise the
Lord. Today is a day for singing.
Oh my
[Music]
soul.
Praise the
Lord.
Oh my soul.
Today is a day for singing that again.
To the mountain, the desert to the
fountain. Oh, I will praise
youord. From the morning to the evening,
as long as I am breathing, today is a
day for singing.
Today is a day to sing.
All right, kiddos. Y'all are dismissed
to your
classes. You guys have fun and love on
your teachers for us. Thank you guys so
much for serving our kids each
[Music]
week. And as they exit, we're going to
transition to the prayers of the people.
So, if you guys would read along and um
speak out the parts in red with
us, Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas,
and for every city and community and all
who live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen. I love you,
Lord. Oh, your
mercy fails
me. And all my
days I've been held in your hands.
From the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head, I will
sing of the
goodness of
[Music]
God. I will sing of you, God. I will
sing.
Let's sing that together. I love you,
Lord. I love you, Lord.
For your mercy fails me.
And all my
days I've been held in your hands.
[Music]
From the moment that I wake
up until I lay my
head, I will
sing of the
goodness of God.
All my
life and all my life you have been
faithful.
[Music]
All my life you have been so so
good. With every breath that I am able,
I will
sing of the
goodness of God. I love your voice. I
love your voice.
[Music]
You have led me through the
fire in darkest night.
You are close like no other.
I've known you as a father.
I've known you as a
friend. And I have lived in the
goodness of God.
And all my life you have been faithful.
And all my life you have been so so
good.
With every breath that I am
able, I will
sing of the
goodness of
God. I will
sing of the
goodness of God.
Your goodness is running after. It's
running after me.
running after
me. With my heart laid down, I surrender
now. I give you everything.
Your goodness is running after. It's
running after me.
And all my life you have been faithful.
And all my life you have been so so
good. With every breath that I am able,
I will
sing of the
goodness of God.
I will
sing of the
goodness of
God. I will
sing of the
goodness of God.
[Music]
We're going to sing This Is My Father's
World next. And this has become my very
favorite hymn. Um, and it's one I kind
of vaguely remember from my childhood
singing occasionally. Um but as an adult
it reminds me of some concrete things
when there are so many complexities and
um it draws me back to things like uh
the holistic love of God that's not just
um calling me forward but has created
this whole universe that's working
together that's supposed to be
displaying his glory displaying his love
um and drawing us into his beauty and
his creativity and um I got to be honest
when I read these words it feels like
I'm in Hobbiton for those of you who are
Lord of the Rings fans um and I love
Hobbitville. I love it so very dearly.
It has a special place in my heart. It
was a a movie that Josh and I watched
like over and over and over and over and
over whenever we first got married
because we didn't have money to pay for
things like Netflix. And I don't
actually think that existed yet to be
honest. I think it was just Red Box and
um satellite maybe and we definitely
didn't have satellite TV. So, so we
watched Lord of the Rings all the time
and the Hobbits just won my love because
it's a simpler life. It was like they
were connected to the earth and they
appreciated it and and they talked about
things like rivers and I don't know
brandy wine shired thingies you know and
um it was just it it's a part of me that
just like gets to enjoy the simplicity
of things and and this song reminds me
of that. So, um, we were sort of joking
beforehand in practice, but imagine your
hobbit home as you sing this song.
Picture what color you would paint the
door because they all had really cool
painted doors in their little hobbit
homes. and um and maybe connect with
this side of God that wants us to just
remember simplicity and the earth that
he created and the goodness of a
babbling brook and a river and a
mountain and the sounds of the birds and
um let's just enjoy um his creation even
from this room tonight.
[Music]
This is my father's
world and my listening
ears. All nature sings
[Music]
around the music of the sphere.
This is my father's
world. I rest me in the
thought of rocks and trees of sky and
seas. His hands the
[Music]
wonder the Morning light. The
liy declare their
[Music]
m. This is my
mother's
world. She shines in all that's
fair. I hear her pass. She speaks to me
everywhere.
[Music]
This is my father's world.
Oh, let me near forget
that though the
wrong so strong, God is the ruler.
This is my father's world.
Why should my heart be sad?
The Lord is king in heaven ring. God
reigns. Let the earth be
glad. The Lord is king. Let the
heavens
go. Let the earth
[Music]
God our father, God our
mother, would you remind us to slow down
this
week to take in the beauty of your
[Music]
creation. to rest in the stillness of a
moment instead of rushing through it and
checking off our to-do list and being a
machine that's productive and efficient
and
fast. Would we slow
down? Would we
listen? Would we take in this
world? Would we bring beauty to
it and recognize the beauty that's
already
there?
Would you shine in all that is around
us? God, open our hearts to your beauty
and your
glory and your
goodness. And let us
rejoice. Let us be glad
again. in Jesus name.
Amen. Would you guys um turn and pass
the peace to your neighbor by saying the
peace of Christ be with
you? Well, grace and peace is
Good to be with you all. So, so good. My
name is Brett. Pronouns he him. And uh
it's a joy a joy to to welcome you into
this space. And as always, that includes
those join us online. Don't forget your
communion elements for later in the
service. Um and also anyone here tonight
who is new. Thanks for for being being
among us. We're so so glad. I know it
can take a lot of courage to walk
through those double doors. So, um,
let's see. We are all right. So, we're
kicking off a new series tonight. And,
uh, I'm excited. I'm excited. It's a
It's a little bit different. So, if
you're with us each week, you know,
generally we follow the church calendar.
So, you know, I mean, for like six
months now, it's just been basically
following the life of Christ. like
Advent and you know he his his birth at
Christmas and then kind of all through
um his life and then to Lent and uh
leading up to the cross and then we had
a resurrection Sunday, you know, Easter
last week. So, it's sort of just been
all that and that's like pretty normal
um here. you know, I I think it's right
um that the church generally just pretty
much, you know, zooms in on Jesus and
what it means to to follow him and how
to love God and then through that, you
know, kind of frame and picture and all
that. So, you know, that's where we
spend most of our time. Um I do think
though this we're now kind of uh
starting to come into what's called
ordinary time. We're not technically
there yet, but we're we're kind of doing
a little early here at the table. Um and
uh what ordinary times about is
basically it's a it's a chance for us to
um kind of talk about different
scriptures and and it's a kind of a
chance where I can do certain series and
things that feel sort of timely or
relevant, you know. So whereas a lot of
the time like the scriptures that I'm
preaching from, they're already like
laid out for me. It's I get a choice
between like four and it's sort of like
well there you go. Um you know, this is
a little different. So, I'm I'm kind of
taking some liberty in this um series
to, you know, to kind of zoom out a
little bit, honestly. So, you'll you'll
uh at times even wonder like uh like
this is a different kind of sermon, you
know, like it's just not maybe as zeroed
in on like this passage or what it means
to follow Jesus's XYZ and it's quite so
granular. I'm I'm really it's almost you
can think of it a little bit meta like a
little bit thinking about how to think
about Christ how to think about
Christian faith how how how do we
understand what in the heck we are doing
here each week and so as opposed to kind
of zooming in and getting into the
details it's sort of zooming out and
asking some bigger kind of framing
questions so that's what this series
will be about so it's titled enchanted
um reclaiming sacred ground in a
disenchanted world and Uh in a lot of
ways this really this sermon will kind
of serve as a kind of an extended
introduction for the series as a whole.
So um so we'll kind of jump right in. So
the title is uh leaving
church unexpected. So our text is Psalm
150 uh verses
1-6 which reads, "Praise the Lord.
Praise God in his sanctuary. Praise him
in his mighty heavens. Praise him for
his acts of power. Praise him for his
surpassing greatness. Praise him with
the sounding of the trumpet. Praise him
with the harp and liar. Praise him with
timber and dancing. Praise him with the
strings in the pipe. Praise him with a
clash of symbols. Praise him with
resounding symbols. Let everything that
has breath. Praise the Lord. Praise the
Lord.
So there's some uh there's some really I
think key questions that start bubbling
up for me when I think of this passage
and um it's questions that are I think
are really facing the really the the
western church in general but you could
even say the American church and and
more specifically like us you know here
at the table. I think this is a a timely
some timely questions. So it's it's
questions like um first why why
praise like just
why and and kind of underneath that
could be you know other questions like
why prayer and why worship why uh really
more broadly kind of why
God you know just why and uh and since
the passage specifically you can tell as
we kind of went through it it's not even
Uh well, it's it's pretty clearly
describing something um more than kind
of like individual spiritual practice,
so to speak. Uh there's um you know,
there's something communal about it,
right? So, this is a little bit more
even than like my personal worship time
or my verse a day app or you know,
there's there's references that kind of
give this hint, right? So, there's um
verse one, it talks about praise God in
his sanctuary, right? So here we have
kind of this reference to the temple and
its core to this place of course where
people in in community right are coming
to worship and then you have all the
references to like with this instrument
and that instrument and that instrument
and that instrument you know so which it
which kind of lends itself again right
to something more like what we just
participated in here as opposed to me
trying to do all those things at once or
something right clearly there's a kind
of communal uh vibe right in this
passage and with the crashing of the
symbols and so forth so Um so if the
first question is like why praise the
second question that comes to mind is
why church?
In other words, uh even if I believe in
say praise or God or prayer or worship
or you know something um why why engage
communal you know expressions of it uh
and you could say of religion in general
but in our case of course like
Christianity and uh you know why not in
other words just keep it kind of private
and uh in other words you know aka no
church or why not just ditch it all um
In other words, why praise? Why prayer?
Why worship? Why why God? So, you know,
I don't know how these questions hit
you. Like, perhaps it sounds somewhat,
you know, self-interested, like, well,
of course, a pastor is going to, you
know, think on these topics. Uh, but I I
think um really the the heart of this
sermon though is to say this isn't these
aren't just um quote unquote religious
questions or private individual
questions, right? That's that's sort of
what I'm going to be driving at in this
message. Um I I think actually these are
really
tremendously relevant questions for our
day, our time. And uh I should also
mention I do ask your forgiveness if you
are here like every Sunday you've heard
pretty much every sermon I've done the
last few years or if you read every
e-letter I put out uh which I know is
probably like two of you but for those
people some of this might be a little
redundant because I am drawing from some
of the stuff I've named in the past. Um,
I'll talk a little bit later about Ian
McIllchrist and such and I've mentioned
him before so um, forgive me. But I I
keep returning to these themes. I just
can't get away from them because they do
feel um so important and and
specifically in a church context where
folks generally have paid quite a high
cost to be here um and are really
there's a lot of folks deconstructing a
lot of folks really wrestling with like
what is all this about? What you know
what are we what are we doing? And um
you know as I kind of survey again the
broader
landscape what I see are people leaving
churches and you know the trends on that
are very clear. uh engagement is down uh
across the board and not just for like
the last five years, the last 10 years,
last 15 years, last 20 years. No, no,
no. For decades, it's just trending. Not
like dropping off a cliff. It's just
sort of gradual, but it's just kind of
uh just things are trending down, right?
And you can say, well, you know, we know
why. It's because church is so it's
history. It's so jacked up. It's, you
know, the the racism and the sexism.
like clear mistreatment of of women and
anti-LGBTQ and you know all the all the
things and I mean of course I at one
level like agree
however if it were only those things
what you'd expect would be people
leaving a kind of conservative more
traditional theological church spaces
and then flocking where flocking to more
progressive liberal you know and so on.
Um but those trends
uh do not don't reflect that. Um in
essence sort of mainline liberal
progressive church nominations also
trending down in fact trending down more
so earlier
um and in more steeply than more
conservative spaces. really it's been
those more conservative spaces that kind
of in recent years actually are kind of
catching up with the trends and are also
kind of evangelicalism for example um
for a long time kind of bucked that
trend but then started in the last say
20 years to kind of decline. Um so you
say well maybe people are leaving you
know Christianity for other religious
traditions. Honestly I was shocked when
I started to look into this because I
that was one of my thoughts was like
yeah maybe that's true. Um, but as I
looked into it, sure enough, nope. No
religious tradition, I mean, across the
board, Buddhism, uh, Hinduism, uh,
Islam, all of, at least specifically,
those these numbers are for the US
specifically, all trending down.
Engagement is down, down, down for
decades. And I was just like, "Wow, I
did not I didn't I didn't I knew I think
probably because I'm familiar with
Christianity, I knew those trends, you
know, I was shocked to hear like, wow,
even with say like immigrant folks, you
know, who would engage I thought maybe
Islam would be trending up and at least
engagement there." Um, but sure enough,
uh, no. So, you know, what what what
kind of happens? Where do folks go?
Well,
um, you know, people, of course, it's
it's not so much like a hard leave
generally, you know, there's a kind of
it's a there's a fading, you know, and
we experience that here at the table,
too. You know, it's it's pretty rare
someone just like, I'm out of here,
never to return, you know, it's not
that. It's it's a kind of just a slow
kind of, you know, a fading. That's what
you see sometimes. It can be
intergenerational, you know, where like
grandma and grandpa were there not just
once a week, they were there every
night, you know, and uh and then and
then parents kind of less so. and the
kids less so and then the grandkids less
you know I mean it's a sort of there can
be a kind of generational thing and
there can also be a thing that kind of
plays out in each of our lives um where
you know we just kind of trend down you
know again maybe not a hard leave but
but a kind of uh not engaging as much as
I as I you know used to so you know
where do folks go as they kind of trend
down so there's a few camps you know
most people tend to retain the label um
you know so like in in surveys and such
they'll still call themselves Christian
um but just you know engagement is very
low because that's what people are
tracking. Um there's another camp that
folks become atheist agnostic. That's a
surprisingly small um camp uh group. The
the largest group is this probably won't
surprise you but it's the spiritual but
not religious crowd. That is one that
trend is trending up. Um though I was
surprised to find it's not as big as I
thought. It's about 20% of Americans
right now consider themselves in that
which is significant. you know, I mean,
that's still millions of people, but
it's not, you know, kind of like 50% of
America, you know, it's not quite that
that dramatic. So, um, in other words,
when people are asked, why
praise? Why
church? Most are tending to answer,
h yeah, I don't know. I don't think it
matters. You know, like that's just the
general kind of vibe. Um, you know, in
essence, the answer is sort of like,
yeah, who cares? You know, like some
people just like different things. You
know, some folks like a a walk on Sunday
nights or in our case nights or most
Sunday mornings. Um, some like to, you
know, play golf on Sundays, some like to
get a little extra work in, you know,
for the work weeks. And, uh, and others
go to, you know, church or temple or
mosque. But in the end, you what does it
really matter, you know? And this is
where my wheels because I've been in
this you know for so many decades and
have been through my own kind of
deconstruction process and wrestling
with what is why praise and why I mean
I've wrestled with all these things um
it's my wheels have been turning and
I've and I've seen a lot of people you
know make this
journey and
uh you know of course at an individual
level I should name right on the outside
I want to give I do believe you know
people should have the freedom to do
what they want so don't hear me as I
kind of proceed this message thinking
like does it think we should go for some
sort of religious theocracy you know
where it's against the law not to go to
church, you know, or something. Uh no, I
I have no interest in s such uh such
things. Um and yet I do believe it
matters and I do think this kind of
trend this sort of fading interest you
know in religion and um and and I what
I'll call serious spirituality by
serious I don't mean you know uh
Christian you know I I mean uh a
spirituality that would be maybe more
than kind of dabbling you know but like
a spirituality where you take on some
practices and even have some beliefs
that involve even a certain sacrifice
you know where it's not just sort of
what's super convenient for
But you know which often manifests in
people um participating in a religious
tradition though not always um but it's
you know but so why this um you know
this kind of fading um and I and I do
yeah I think this trend I think it
matters and um I think this fading kind
of commitment is really it's a sign of
the times and it's part of a of a much
deeper broader cultural trend.
that I actually find deeply um
troubling. So, as I've mentioned um in
previous sermons, the the most helpful
writer and thinker I found on all these
trends and um there are many I love
Charles Taylor on this topic, James K.
Sarah Kley, Marilyn Robinson. If y'all
are anyone's curious and wants to like
jump in the thing, you know. Okay. Well,
those are some names. But the one I
found most helpful uh is Ian Gilchrist.
His book, The Master and Emissary. Um
The Divided Brain, the Making of the
Western World. Again, I know I quoted
him just a few months ago, but um I
just, man, when I read his book uh would
be last summer, it just it blew my mind.
I was like, "Oh my gosh, this is such
good language, the broader trends I
see." And he basically names um kind of
in his book, we're only we're not seeing
the whole. We're seeing parts. We're
seeing this change and this change
culturally and this change culturally
and this change and this change and this
change and this change and this change
says we don't understand. We don't we
can't see it whole. We don't understand
that it's actually all one
thing. And what what is some of that
that thing? So you can tell from his his
book he he talks about the contrasting
roles of the of the brain's
hemispheres and he um so that the two
parts right if you look at a brain the
most obvious thing is it's split in two
with the corpus colosum connecting them
and there was some early kind of
research into this that went really
sideways and people thought like oh but
it got kind of discredited so people
honestly neuroscientists and others kind
of dropped it like yeah this is sort of
dumb we shouldn't really study the
gymosphere it doesn't make any sense uh
but the gillchrist um kind of circled
back to it and did a neuroscience degree
and and ended up he's really changed the
field and had a huge influence um and
that he realized it's not so much that
they just do different things. He says
the two hemispheres and really thus
human beings right I mean what
influences us more than our brains it's
like you know you you change someone's
brain you change them you know what I
mean like it's dramatic we know this
from like stroke victims and you know
it's just like whoa this is or or a
tumor grows and someone's personality
completely change you know it's just
dramatic so he says it's not so much
that they just do different things it's
he says the two hemispheres they attend
and allow us to attend to the world in
different ways
Hang with me. I am going somewhere. Just
to say I know you're like this is a
neuroscience lecture. Uh so what's the
left hemisphere about? Uh its approach
to the world is analytical, detail
oriented, reductionistic, linear,
propositional, mechanistic, abstract,
fragmented, categorizing and
controlling. Uh the right hemisphere
approach is holistic, contextual,
integrative, metaphorical, relational,
experiential, intuitive, open, and
ambiguous. Now,
uh if that first list of the left
hemisphere, if that just if if you're
hearing me say those are negative or
bad, um you're misunderstanding. So,
this is it's it's these are good, right?
The the ability to think analytically is
freaking wonderful, right? the the
capacity to categorize to separate
things that's like essential. However,
uh the we might say is the left
hemisphere is a very good servant and a
very poor
master. And of course, that's why McIll
named his book the master and his
emissary, right? because he believes
that human beings function best when the
right hemisphere and its activities are
in the driver's seat. So not not just
the only thing that matters but but in
the driver's seat with the left
hemisphere sort of in the car but taking
directions from the
right. And so what's happened though
over the over the last 500 years or so?
But we are slowly but surely, right? And
you can see where as human beings with
our technology and and our culture and
the way it's going, especially in the
west, what's happening? We are reshaping
the world into a left hemisphere
dominant one, right? A world of analysis
and abstraction and categorization and
data and bureaucracy and control.
Right? I mean, if you want to be a
success economically right now, what
industry should you go into? Write him
spirit
poetry. Wamp, you know, no, like you're
in the star. It's the classic starving
artist. You know what I mean? Like
there's no you want to go into AI,
frankly. You know what I mean? Like
that's the future. That's the right. And
what is it? That's go into something
that's analytical, detail- oriented,
reductionistic, linear, propositional,
mechanistic, abstract, fragmented,
categorizing, controlling. That's the
that's the world, you know, I mean, and
again, to be clear, not demonizing, that
not saying you shouldn't work in those
industry. That's just the world we live
in, you know, just all of us to some
degree are we're living in this, you
know, we're this is how we are. Um, so
that's the present and the near future,
right? In essence, we're just living in
this world where our brains are are
shifting towards the left hemisphere
where our leaders are increasingly left
hemisphere dominant, right? Think uh
Bill Gates, think whole Elon, you know.
Um, so in essence, we appreciate our
poets and our artists and our religious
leaders, but frankly, Taylor Swift or
Echartle or Pope Francis, God rest his
soul, um, aren't exactly calling the
shots on the future of the world. They
have an influence. They have a voice
certainly, um, but they're not in the
driver's seat, to use that metaphor
again, right? They're not they're not in
the driver's seat. So we can and we will
talk in this series about the many ways
this is playing out in our world from I
mean it touches everything from our kind
of weird abstract takes on truth um
that'll be a sermon in a few weeks to
our disembodied knowledge work in our
jobs to our disenchanted view of sex and
sexual relationships and on and on and
on. Uh one I don't know if we'll do a
sermon on it but something uh Chris
mentions is even the way we view um one
another and our
bodies is shifting. We know this because
when they've studied stroke victims, if
you have a right hemisphere or stroke
and that kind of shuts down and you have
a left hemisphere, the way people relate
to their bodies is completely different.
Like it's it's a like it's like an
alien. It's like not you don't see it as
you you see it as like it's like a
machine. It's a I mean it's like
fascinating and and kind of disturbing.
So writing on that he says um although
it might seem that we overvalue the body
and physical existence in general this
is not what I deduce from our
preoccupation with exercise health and
diet. The body has become a
thing a thing we possess a
mechanism even if a mechanism for fun a
bit like a sports car with a smart sound
system. That mechanistic view derives
from the 19th century scientific world
picture which has lingered with us
longer in biology, in the life sciences,
in physics. The body has become an
object in the world like other objects
as the French philosopher Ponti here. So
in essence, why are the arts
suffering? Why is poetry fading? Why is
education not called STEM maligned?
Why is religion and spirituality used
and kind of deployed either for purely
political purposes in
that wickedness that is Christian
nationalism or banished to the private
sphere, right? Just well me and my
little my little
spirituality. Why is this? Because all
things right
hemisphere I would add all things really
just deeply deeply human right are very
suspect that there is something rather
dead and
machineike about so much of modern life.
Right? We have now this diminished
capacity for metaphor, for embodied
experience, for spiritual depth. And
that is leading to a disenchantment.
It's leading to a loss of meaning and a
reduction in the richness of human life.
We are living in an increasingly left
hemisphere dominated world. So back to
our text, why praise?
Why
church? Because praise reminds us that
the world is more than freaking
data and
analysis and
[Music]
control, right? Because church reminds
us that we're embodied and connected and
not alone. Because we need
sanctuaries. We need spaces that
rehumanize us, that re-enchant the
world, that reconnect us to the mystery
of
God because we need poetry and metaphor
and liturgy and theology. Not because
they abandon reason or language, but
because they they use reason and
language, but they kind of sort of um
see through them, right? They take us
somewhere. We might say that all our God
talk is pointing to something, something
beyond
words. God will never be reduced to the
words of my left hemisphere. God is
always more than I can name. All our
songs, they're reaching out for
something, something beyond music. But
that music, it
participates in it. And this is why I
believe the most profound worship in
spiritual practice ultimately leads us
to a place of
silence because it's
there that that we simply open ourselves
naked and vulnerable to the quiet work
of the Holy Spirit in us beyond any
words or images or concepts beyond
anything my left hemisphere can
understand or imagine.
So, in closing, I know that's a lot. So,
let me try and kind of kind of uh sum
this up with some implications. I'll
have six of them. Number one, they'll be
quick though. Number one, worship is
resistance. Worship is resistance.
I'll get more into this in my next
sermon in this series. But I think
because so many of us, myself included,
are coming out of worked and abusive and
toxic religious
spaces, we are very tempted to think
that freedom is simply leaving the
practice of either Christianity or
spirituality or religion behind
altogether.
not realizing that we actually need what
we'll call the the mega the meta
narrative the the grand the big story
and the practices that something like
Christian faith actually offers in order
to push back on the worst of this sort
of bland strange technoc capitalist
consumerrist overly left hemisphere
dominant culture that's become becoming
less human and meaningful by the day. In
short, worship, I think especially in
its more communal aspects is a it's a
it's a countercultural act in this
disenchanted,
hyperrational
individualistic world, right? It's not
just singing
songs. It It's a declaration that the
world is
sacred, that still infused with meaning
and that mystery
matters. That of course is gibberish to
the left hemisphere, but it makes
perfect sense to the right. Uh second
implication, prioritize embodied
community. Church is so much more than
just like
beliefs. It really is about
bodies in a room together. It's about
sound.
in movement, in presence and shared
experience. And so I encourage you to
prioritize showing up not just for the
sake of you know attendance or something
but because your physical presence
matters in an increasingly
disembodied and thinking um not just
here on Sundays but but meetups are
another expression of this. Service
opportunities we go into the community
you know um are all the same. Third,
make space in your life for the right
hemisphere. Again, we live in a world
dominated by analysis and productivity.
And so, intentionally cultivate
practices that that start to ner kind of
nurture your your um kind of more
holistic, metaphorical,
um
relational,
emotional, experiential side. Things
like prayer and music and silence and
poetry and storytelling. Um I think this
is the kind of radical of spiritual
practices is that it attunes us to all
of these things.
Um, yeah, they're in essence, you can
think of them, they're kind of like
medicine for your for your soul. Fourth,
re-enchant the ordinary.
Start
noticing start naming the the sacred in
your daily life. Whether it's just, you
know, a quick walk in the park, a shared
meal, a simple moment of awe, just let
the praise of Psalm 150 expand beyond
Sunday and get into your week. Right?
Faith isn't it's just not just a
building. It's a it's a lens through
which we see and experience all things.
Christian churches aren't for
everyone. Maybe that's a strange thing
for pastor to say, but uh I don't think
it is. I think, you know, if you have
been spiritually abused or
traumatized, it's okay to step
back. It's okay. Like I understand there
may be people who have so gone through
it. They just can't. They can't come to
those doors and be here. They just
can't. And that's
okay. What I would encourage you to do
though is not to let that wound cut you
off from spiritual community
altogether. Right? Don't don't stop at
simply disengaging
because that sacred view of the world
still
matters. So I I just implore you like
find a religious space where your soul
can breathe, where your love for God can
be nourished. I know that brings up all
sorts of complicated questions of
interreligious dialogue and afterlife
and you know all that. We you can feel
free to email me. I have many thoughts
on all that. Um but suffice to say I
don't think if someone engages in
another religious tradition that they're
burning in hell forever. You know I
don't think that's accurate. Um sixth
and finally commitment to your own local
church or I could have you know temple
or mosque or somewhere. I think it
really matters. And in many ways, I just
want to say take a moment just to say
thank you to all of you um
who really have not been willing to
forsake praise and prayer and
community and this chance to kind of
come together and love and listen and
discern God's heart. To all of you who
you've been giving like your your time
and energy and money to help make the
table and other churches um throughout
your life happen. And I just want to say
thank you. It it it in this modern
world, it increasingly just seems like a
somewhat foolish thing, you know, a
little bit outdated, you know, just not
with the times. Uh quaint, weird,
impractical, unscientific.
No, no, no, no, no, no,
no. I think it is holy. I think it is
central. That's all I got for you. In
the name of the father, the son, and
holy spirit. Amen.
So on the night that Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal with his
disciples. And at that meal, he held a
loaf of bread and he broke it. He said,
"Take it and eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." And he held him a cup
of wine. He said, "Take this drink. This
is my blood. It's shed for you. Whenever
you eat this bread, whenever you drink
this cup, remember me. So for thousands
of years now, we've come to the table to
reenter on the God who is love, to
reenter on his son, Jesus Christ. So I
encourage you to participate in this
time in that that kind of spirit of
reverence and awe and wonder and beauty
and mystery that is appropriate to. So
the way we'll participate you tonight,
we'll just go row by row starting here
at the front and we'll just form one
line right here in the middle. So when
one row is done, the next one can go
ahead and jump in line. We practice
what's called an open table here.
Meaning if if you're here today and
you'd like to participate regardless of
your exact, you know, theology or
denomination or something, um you're
free to to participate if you would like
to. Having said that, there's no
pressure. If you're not that you want to
do that, that's fine, too. You should
know the red is wine, the white is great
juice.
And then finally, you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like. Some
folks like to come and kneel here at the
front. Others uh partake immediately.
Others return to their seats. No one
will lead you through the exact moment.
You just do that on your own. So this
is not
church, but
of ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more. So you
who have much faith and you have
little been here often and you who have
not been here long, you who have tried
to follow and you who feel like you
failed, come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want
should come to
[Music]
We're going to close out tonight with um
a song that you may be familiar with if
you grew up in youth group. Um it's
called God of Wonders. And again, the
lyrics are just kind of reminding us of
this bigger picture of of tuning in to
our right hemisphere and um connecting
with creation and beauty and creativity.
So, you guys want to stand with us as we
sing this last one?
[Music]
Lord of all
creation, of water, earth and sky.
[Music]
Glory to the Lord on
high God of wonders beyond our galaxy.
You are
holy,
holy. The universe praise your
majesty. You are
holy,
holy, Lord of heaven and earth.
Lord of heaven and
earth. Early in the
[Music]
morning I will cate the light.
When I stumble in the darkness,
I will call your name by night.
God of wonders beyond our galaxy.
You are holy,
[Music]
holy. The universe declares your
majesty.
You are
holy, holy,
Lord of heaven and earth. Lord of heaven
and earth. Lord of heaven and earth.
Lord of heaven and earth.
Hallelujah to the Lord of heaven and
earth.
Halleluah to the Lord of heaven and
Hallelujah to the Lord of heaven and
earth.
Holy,
[Music]
holy and precious Lord, reveal your
heart to me.
Father, hold
me. Hold
me. The universe declares your majesty.
You are holy.
[Music]
Holy,
holy,
holy
Lord God
Almighty.
Early in the
morning, our song shall rise to thee.
[Music]
Holy,
holy,
[Music]
merciful and
mighty
God in
three. Blessed
[Music]
precious reveal your heart to me.
Father
me. The universe declares your majesty.
You are holy.
Holy. Thank you so much for joining us
this evening.
If you are new, we would love for you to
fill out a card at the table on your way
out or just scan the QR code. That way,
we can answer any questions that you may
have and just say thank you for
visiting. Generosity is a key aspect of
life and adoration and worship. To give
financially, you can scan the QR the QR
code or visit the table at tx.org.
If you call Table Home and don't
currently serve on a ministry team, we'd
love to have you try one out. There's
tech team, kids ministry, and host team
are currently the most in need. Fill out
a card on the table or scan the QR code
to sign
up. All right, let me send you into your
week with this blessing.
You may hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these
words. You are a child of
God.
You are a child of
God. This is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead filled
with this yet to be determined highs and
lows and everything in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved. You are
worthy. You are
accepted just as you are. and go filled
with God's Holy Spirit and the desire to
extend these same gifts of grace and
unconditional love to everyone you come
in contact
with. Be blessed. Have a good week and
we hope to see you back here next
Sunday. Good night.
[Music]